[Music]
on today's show we talk about how to
tell your kids about school shootings
and other tragedies we have a follow-up
call with a woman who had a hard
conversation with her in-laws about
covet and boundaries and we talked to a
woman about how to tell her daughter
that her husband's lost his faith stay
tuned
[Music]
what up what up what up this is john
with the dr john dolone's show man i'm
so glad you're with us hope you're doing
well hope your new year's off to a great
start
[Music]
hope you are keeping all of your uh what
do you call them resolutions
you can say traditions but that's not a
thing but keeping resolutions
if you don't make them you're like oh
i'm too cool for resolutions well cool
make some it's not too late
otherwise i hope you're doing well man
hope you're doing well kelly james y'all
doing well it's good to see the whole
band back together good track you all
have been off taking care of your
families and
vacationing and all those things like i
said it's good to be back moving oh yeah
man that means a lot
it makes my heart feel good kelly cause
after we spend a lot of time together
most people are like that's enough
deloney for all of us for a while
so it makes me makes me happy that
you're glad to be back well i get paid
to be here yeah see he had to go ruin it
we're having a moment and there it went
there went
um okay so this is awesome so you know
those
[Laughter]
i get a text i'm sitting in the woods um
i get a text from
john falcons who's a leader here at this
company he's like one of the fancy pants
he's real smart and all that stuff
and he's got a picture of one of the uh
conversation cards
and he just says
for the record my family hates you
something like that i was like what's
your problem
well one of the questions
by the way if you've got little kids in
the in the car and you still are playing
the game cool you may want to pause
right now
one of the cards in the conversation
cards is when did you find out santa
claus was a lie
who told you
well he hadn't told his kids who are
basically college age by the way
falcons i know she's nine the kids are
nine that's basically college that's
that's oh that's i mean in my defense
anyway he left him laying around kids
found him
and it was like what
and then he said after their
conversation a couple days later she
came back and she's like easter bunny
and he was like nope
just deloney ruining everybody's
families
number one listen
nine's pushing it do your kids know
james
um
your nine-year-old still in
no i don't have a nine-year-old but
my eight-year-old still in yeah she's
gonna ride this one huh i've always
thought that the conversation starter
cards from a distance kind of look like
a pack of cigarettes agreed it'd be
hilarious if like there was a surgeon
general's warning style looking thing
that said it may not yeah may ruin your
kid's childhood well they had hidden the
couple's one but they just hadn't hidden
the uh family one
or the adult whatever dude good job way
to go to loney thanks man
off to a great start here in 20 whatever
what year are we in 2022
good job all right let's go to detroit
rock city let's just change the show
here let's go to detroit rock city talk
to seth what's up brother seth how are
we doing
hey good man thanks for having me on you
got it dude what's up
um hey hold on you got you have kids uh
yeah four of them how old are they
nine i didn't hear the whole
conversation though so i'm not sure i
can weigh in but we've got a
nine-year-old is your nine-year-old
two-year-old one-year-old does your
nine-year-old know about santa claus
she knows the truth i should say yeah
there you go well done
that's all i'm saying all right dude so
what's up man
all right well um
my family and i live about 20 minutes
from this old this whole oxford
situation
man yep
um so i guess you know
out of respect like we don't
have any kids that go to oxford we don't
have really intimate friends or family
that go there but um i can't it's
unimaginable what they're going through
yeah but we're sitting 20 minutes away
with schools that have been on lockdown
and
threats everywhere and and two of our
kids having um
two of our kids being school-aged and
we're just
trying to figure out how do we talk to
them about what's going on appropriately
good call man
so
for those who
haven't paid attention or just you know
it's
this show will air a month or two later
um oxford shooting where the young man
went into high school um i guess he got
his dad's gun and opened fire
and um
killed some young kids some teenagers
and
the whole thing's been a mess injured a
bunch of people and it's been a mess
um
and yeah we often think about that
tragedy there that joe's tragedies have
are you know have an epicenter obviously
but they they ricochet through our
families and through everything and here
you are a parent of four young ones
asking are we gonna is it okay to go to
school right
right so you're 20 minutes away walk us
through like you get the first call and
the second call and then if you're like
most of us i need to put my eyes on my
kids right now like walk us through what
you experienced
yeah so
um
i i have enough physical therapy
practice so i was with patients most of
the day and i kind of missed most of
what was happening
but i got some messages from my wife
kind of towards the end of the day and
it was mostly just second hand i don't
think we really knew the extent of what
was going on until i got home yeah
and
our kids fortunately well not
fortunately
they were sick so they weren't in school
yeah
i should say one was at home one was at
school
we
just kind of were in shock i guess we
didn't really talk about it much that
evening
because we didn't really know what to
say and my wife and i just were
trying to sort through the details and
understanding ourselves i guess
man so have your kids ask questions
um
yeah and i guess that's part of my
question too right is
they haven't asked a lot of questions
and i'm not really sure how far to dig
um for their emotions and their feelings
um and
they
you know our son is in transitional
kindergarten
he's he was a five-year-old and they
went into lockdown as soon as this thing
happened yeah and he came home just
saying kind of you know hey i was really
brave today and
you know we did this thing and he
described it like it was no big deal
yeah
and our daughter on the other hand uh
going back into fourth grade the day
after i think you know she heard a lot
of stuff from
a lot of different opinions kind of all
over the school so
they haven't asked a lot of details
about what happened yeah um but we're
just
and we've had conversations with them
already honestly um and you're honestly
your show's been helpful in that way i
appreciate that but i
i just don't know um i guess i'm worried
about how
much they will internalize this thing
because
when we look at the behavior over the
past week or so here
um you know they're both back in our bed
every single night there's just a lot of
like
there's a lot of stuff that tells us
that everyone's amped up right now there
you go even though no one's seeing it
there's that make sense yep yeah
all right and i want to make sure we
honor that and i don't really know how i
don't really know how to go about that
dude your kids are so lucky to have you
man i'm like [ __ ] you
i'm glad that there's dads like you out
there raising kids like you're raising
it's good man like i'm grateful for you
and um
so yeah we i mean we can you and i could
go grab drink and talk about this for a
while these kind of things rattle me um
because i've been to these scenes right
i've shown up to these situations where
there's still blood on the wall where
there's i mean where there's a mess and
um it's
these i got a visceral response as we
all do right we all do yeah and if you
got little kids and it's 20 minutes down
the road it it's a whole other level all
right and then every the whole thing's a
mess man
um so here's a couple things that i keep
in mind here okay
the first thing is this
kids are looking for models
of feelings because they have them
and
they when they
a lot of times adults
we want to put on a brave face we want
to show that we are strong we want to
show that we are unphased that we the
day is still going on
and the challenge with like that's i get
the the sentiment there
but a kid feels terrified and if he
looks to the people that he trusts the
most and sees or
she he or she looks to the people they
trust the most and they don't
acknowledge sadness terror
being scared or whatever
they feel crazy
and the way a kid deals with feeling
crazy is you know 50 different ways but
they will try to do what they can to
nuzzle up next to their parents by
like causing chaos being bananas uh
being perfect little angels what if
those are all coping mechanisms to try
to get back into relationship so one of
the things i would do with your
nine-year-old and again this is all like
my friend rachel cruz she says share
don't scare
all these are age-appropriate
conversations
um
but let's let's start with your
nine-year-old i would if this happens in
my house i would take my nine-year-old
and we'd go for a walk somewhere and i
would tell him hey or we get coffee i'd
look him in the eye make sure he sees me
and tell him
hey you know this thing that happened
i'm really really sad
and it makes me really scared that
somebody would do this and that sounds
counter-intuitive
but it's it's freeing for a child it
makes them feel not insane and then they
get to see hey i'm scared and
i'm still gonna go take care of my body
i'm i'm scared and i'm still gonna hug
mom we're still gonna go through our
routine and then they start to learn oh
it's okay to have feelings and they
don't control everything right
and so giving them that gap letting him
know i've i'm your dad i'm a grown man i
got a i got a pt practice i'm crushed
i'm doing great
i'm tough
and i get scared too
and it's okay to say there's you know
there's there's an uncertainty there
that i want him to understand that you
get
um when it comes to like like a younger
kid they come home and they say hey i
was really brave today
i think it's good to ask one more
question
like what were you brave from why did
they make you go into that room and let
them know yeah somebody um
somebody did something bad today they
hurt some people
um somebody was sick and they made some
really
bad mistakes it was scary mom and dad
were really scared and i'm glad that
you're safe and then hug the daylights
out of them
and let them know huh mom and dad get
scared and right so we're teaching them
these things now i wouldn't say
you know a gunman went in and opened
fire on a school i wouldn't give that
level of detail to a four-year-old
but i would let him know yeah somebody
was sick and they hurt a lot of people
and i was scared that you got hurt but
i'm so grateful that you're not hurt
right does that make sense
yeah for sure um
the kid kids are asking am i crazy are
my feelings normal
they're asking am i safe
and that's what touch does for a kid
like i'm here
and presence does and then they ask
who's in control and i think that's
where
you don't tell a nine-year-old like yeah
this crap happens man like we're just
gonna have to roll with it you don't
want to pass that sort of chaos onto a
nine-year-old but there's something
about
um
i'm gonna control what i can control and
i'm gonna love you and then we're all
still gonna go to bed in our own beds
right yeah and it's okay to have a
season where they come over home and
like just for a couple of nights they're
gonna stay on our bed i'm okay with that
man i just i i'll never forget this i'll
say this i'll never forget i was with my
partner and we were out of the scene um
oh man it's
gruesome it was a gruesome scene and
it it
it's happened one time and it was with a
kid
a child and i told my partner i gotta
step out and that's the cardinal sin you
never leave your partner her name is
jenny she's like she was incredible she
um
but she i had a little girl
and i stepped out of that situation was
too close to home
the whole thing was a mess
i helped on the outside and she took
care of inside stuff
and i got home probably 2 a.m i think 1
a.m 2 a.m 3 a.m and i went in and
welcomed my kid i mean he was half
asleep but i went and woke him up and
hugged him and that wasn't for him that
was for me
you know what i mean and that's okay and
there's probably some comfort interviews
you've done a fair amount of that there
you go right um i want i don't want your
kids to think that
um their job is to prop you up
right all right
but
i needed to hug my kid
i needed to make sure he was still
breathing i know that sounds bonkers um
until you've been in the middle of it
but i just i needed to check in and
that's okay now that's not his job but i
need to check in so um as long as it
doesn't become six months from now and
they're still sleeping in your bed or
four months or an hour three months from
now um they need to know that the
routine is important that control is
important you get up and do the right
thing every day um and that mom and dad
still love you but we're gonna be back
to our beds but i think a couple of
nights of tethering in is gonna be big
um
how are you okay it's scary
it's not a lot of yeah we don't think
about ourselves enough sometimes i think
but we
uh
i don't know i'm doing i'm doing okay i
think i stay busy a lot yeah how's your
wife
i think overall it's been a really tough
couple of weeks yeah that's the reality
yeah
so
i would recommend you sit down with your
wife and
hold one or both of your hands and have
a moment of vulnerability and just say
hey
we got four little kids how are we doing
this is hard
and sometimes those unspoken things you
get busy and you go back to work and she
doesn't want to bother you with she's
terrified or you don't want to bother
her with it and you kind of get you get
that you get that gap
and that gap grows over time and i think
checking in with your spouse and saying
hey
how are we like how are you i know this
is heavy and maybe she hasn't felt
permission to cry yet or she has cried a
lot she doesn't do it again or maybe you
haven't had permission just to go man
this sucks
but i do think it's important to check
back in with each other
i think that would be good cool
well brother i'm grateful for you man
thank you so much for being there with
our kids
to everybody listening
we could do a whole show on this stuff
man what an absolute disaster what an
absolute mess
um
your kids want to know are their
feelings okay
and the answer is yes and the only way
they can they you can't tell them that
you got to show them
you got to show them
then they need to see what adults do
which is then they get up
and they'd be about healing
and if this kind of stuff overwhelms you
call somebody
this is an excuse to
go back and
you know hit the pantry or go skip all
your work this is the time you got to
double down on taking care of everybody
take care of yourself taking care of
your relationships
model that for our kids model that for
the people that work for you model that
for your spouse
and be gentle
what a mess man it's a call brother
we'll be right back in the doctor john
dolan show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right next up we're going to go out
to the slc in salt lake city
and this is a follow-up called
you wrote back you called back how are
you
i'm in finals and off of a graveyard
shift so i'm surviving
what are you what are you in finals for
recreation therapy
wow so is this what stage of the program
are you in
i uh this is my second to last semester
and then i have internship and then i'm
in it
dude sister ness you were so close man
you're almost done yeah yeah that's
great are you gonna pass your finals
oh yeah i have like a's in all my
classes but it's just a lot of paper
writing so i'm not too worried about it
i'm just gonna flex a little bit i got i
got straight
dude way to go that's awesome all right
so thank you
back in march march of
night march 19th
we had a show that was all about coven
because why not right nobody else was
talking about it so we figured we would
go ahead and do it
and you wrote in here's your original
email here's what you wrote
said all
are in law uh uh
our in-laws are taking our covert
precautions as a personal attack and
it's breaking down our relationship
when they are not willing to take
responsibility for their own actions and
will not take time to understand what
our perspective is and why we are taking
precautions to protect our baby how do
we navigate the damage relationship so
you and your husband had boundaries
your in-laws
thought y'all were idiots
and
then things went sideways and we chatted
for a while
and then you wrote back in so so tell me
what's going on what happened how's it
going
all the stuff and oh my gosh
i don't fully know how this call goes
and so you may be calling to be like i
do what you said you idiot and uh
way to go and now i don't have a home or
a family like so i'm i'm anxious to hear
how this ends up so tell me what
happened
so uh back in march i was obviously in a
really low spot uh i was in a career
level not even a career i was in a
stepping stone job it's not even a
career
yeah it was a stepping stone job that
really was taken out of me
relationships were breaking down and uh
things got really really bad
and it got to a certain point where
like my in-laws weren't talking to me
anymore everything was through my
husband even if i reached out to them to
make plans they would reply back to my
husband only gosh they're foot
four-year-olds so hold on so you this is
after
you said hey if are going to come visit
the
the baby here's how it's going to go
yeah okay yeah so basically over the
gosh
it probably was about six months of just
awful
relationship stuff kind of
i i got really bad panic attacks let's
just say that like yeah your family felt
like it was coming apart well hey take
us back real quick take us back to the
did you have a
final boundaries conversation did you
send a letter like what did you do how
did you come to say this is the way this
is going to be because this is my house
and my kid
sure so and where the heck was your
husband in all this
so he was
it's complicated because his
relationship with his parents and even
like all of his brother's relationship
the whole family dynamic they don't talk
and so
it was basically like i know that you're
hurting and i'm really sorry
um but if you talk to them about it it's
just going to stir the part this pot and
make it way way way worse
we're we're actually moving out of state
in like a year and so it was his way of
trying to like
keep the peace before we take off let's
just write it out
yeah let's let this thing die slowly
yeah
exactly and it was just really tough on
me because
let me take you back a little bit
further so i grew up um
in like with childhood i had
trichotillomania i had to go to
a therapy to be able to even
talk about my emotions or express myself
and that is something that i carried
with me my whole entire life was
something i held in very high regard of
i'm able to communicate and that's a big
part of all my relationships so i felt
like i regressed a lot
um into internalizing and bodily
bottling things up
and i was on like i was really pissed
off
and i was on a walk in the middle of the
night probably at like 2 a.m just trying
to
calm my nerves and i was just like you
know what enough enough i don't have
anything else to lose they need to know
how this is affecting me because i'm
sick i'm just i'm straight up sick and
i'm tired and i'm working nights now i'm
a spike tech so that's like a lot
yeah
you work in the graveyard shift at a
psych hospital oh yeah get it
dude my favorite unit so i like the high
acuity so it's a really good time yeah
yeah hey but let me let me ask you this
this is not why you're calling you're
calling to tell me like what's going on
right but yeah so but
you're
we'll talk about that at the end is it
okay if i like if i okay we'll talk
about this at the end i want to derail
you here but
okay either way it's fine okay go ahead
go ahead go ahead okay and so i
at that next night shift i
it was really quiet and i just decided
um i listened to you guys a lot or you a
lot and i was really thinking about the
letter thing i was like do i write them
a letter i feel like they're not really
gonna understand my intention because
they just take things like
so far out of context they're children
but i still wanted to like write stuff
down just for like my own processing
absolutely so i basically spent like the
whole 12-8 hour shift
drafting this like front and back 10
page essay
about how everything was affecting me
and how i mean i've been a part of their
family for eight years and so all of the
shift over the past two almost two years
now
was very devastating for me and not
something that i you know wanted to
continue on with
and so i held on to that and i didn't
talk to my husband about it and i just
kind of sat on that for a while
and
i finally went to my husband and like
hey look i know you don't want me to
talk to your parents about this because
it will stir the pot but i'm unwell i
can't do this anymore and i they need to
know the worst that's going to happen is
they continue to not talk to me
and nothing really changes but at least
they know
where i'm at yeah
and so i called them up
what did he say to them and
he just said i trust you do what you
need to do to be okay and i'm like and
you don't have to be there i can do this
by myself but i would like your support
you don't even have to say anything but
just to have you in the room to like
have my back type of thing
um hey so i i'm having like a visceral
reaction to this
is that okay i didn't mean i don't want
to get
get in the middle of your marriage but
that sounds like he's choosing
peacekeeping in them over
like his wife is ill
they are suffocating his wife and he's
not stepping in to go not on my watch
you're not doing that
yeah it was a weird time it was a weird
time it sounds like weird is a really
really kind way of saying it was an
awful time
yeah yeah
um
he just was afraid you know like yeah
he's never gotten that deep and even
him
i mean i i understand his perspective
he's stuck between a rock and a hard
place of trying to maintain a
relationship with his parents with you
know but they didn't want a relationship
with they didn't want a relationship
with y'all
tell you was listening to rocking a hard
place sounds like
yeah anyway that's a whole other
conversation i don't want to stir it i
don't want you to get off the phone and
be like hey husband you suck but no i
also we worked a lot on that in the last
couple months so um all right keep going
like i i don't know i wish he was on the
phone because i'd be like bro you
unaccepted unacceptable it went on a
little bit too long we'll just say that
eight years too long but go ahead
so i i called them and it was a very
awkward phone call and i was just like
hello
i would
like to invite you over i have some
things that i need to get off of my
heart and
i just need to talk with you guys face
to face
um but at this point they're seeing my
husband and my son basically every
single week so all of that drama has
kind of subsided things have kind of
calmed down a little bit
um but i just like wasn't okay and so
were they were they were they
they were they respecting the banners
you'd set up
yeah yeah we kind of got past i mean
most of that happened because my
brother-in-law's baby got covered and so
then they were like oh okay
so there's that but besides the point um
and so
they said okay we'll come over at this
time i had them come over when my son
went to bed so there was no like
distraction of
baby stuff and things like that
and it was really kind of ironic because
they ended up
showing up super like an hour and a half
late and they would only they were
texting my husband about showing up late
and i was like oh that's exactly what
i'm talking about
um so they get there
uh to my apartment and like we him i
have him sit down and i pull out my
papers and i have my tea and i'm
profusely sweating and super shaky
and nervous and i just
dude you're all out there you're a
gangster nessa
thank you
like people are like no dude the house
is on fire i went in and grabbed the you
know got the cat out all right
no dude you stared down your in-laws and
your cowardly husband just i know was he
like what was he brushing his teeth or
something what was he doing like i'm
just gonna go
he was actually he was actually sitting
in between his parents it was very
interesting
they kind of just sat there and i was
like i have this bean bag and i just
like put the bean bag in front of
everybody and i was like all right we're
about to have a conversation
would you like any water
this is screwed up in so many ways but
go ahead
and so
i
basically
censored because my
letter that i wrote was very angry yeah
and you know profanity was used so i i
skimmed through my maybe you didn't
sense your maybe maybe you were wise
right you filtered yeah not centered you
filtered and it's good for all of us i'm
filtering right now because i'm i'm
starting to get raged out on your
husband but go ahead i'm filtering um
and
he sat between his parents while you
talked well he he sat well i mean there
was
it was it's really not as bad as it
sounds he was sounds super bad all right
go ahead go ahead go ahead yeah
and
i basically said i basically spent like
30 minutes straight talking and that's
the first time
that they have never interrupted me or
like stopped listening to what i had to
say did he tell them what was coming did
he like tip him off no
nope but i feel like i set the tone
pretty well when i just like sat in
front of him and then i had like you
know a whole
novel in my hand
and i'm sure you were hardcore all right
so they
they didn't take it well
actually they did and i was extremely
surprised okay
like so my mother-in-law she she speaks
a lot just like kind of without
thought
and
um and and so does my father-in-law they
just say whatever's on their mind
regardless of how it might reality or
facts or data yeah there you go and and
so then my father-in-law
it was a long pause for a really long
time and then my father-in-law was like
all right honey before
we say anything let's really think about
this
about our responses
they're finally in the presence of a
mature adult and they're like oh i like
the way this feels
yeah so
they kind of spun some stuff back on me
and i i called him out on it i'm like
look this is not okay you know
x y and z whatever
all the stuff that was going on
and
talked about like the text message that
my father-in-law sent which has like
other stuff to do he kind of lied about
that called him out on it
and um so it's really just like i'm like
i have nothing to lose at this point you
just need to know the truth about how
your
behaviors
and how this relationship is affecting
me
yes yes way to go this is awesome
yeah it felt really really really really
good yes but it sounds like you weren't
you weren't vindictive and you weren't a
maniac and you weren't scaring and
yelling and knocking sounds like you
were an assassin
i was basically talking like at this
tone in this case throughout the whole
thing heaping burning coals like you
thought this through you felt your
emotions you went and moved your body
you let them work through you wrote it
all down and then you said now it's time
yeah oh my gosh gosh
yes dude your husband doesn't deserve
you i don't even met you that guy
jeez
and so then at that at a certain point
um my husband he did jump in and he
started talking about his boundaries and
how he felt
um with the things that they were saying
to him about his parenting and him being
like a father
so after his wife went and hit the first
guy and he fell down he's like yeah and
he ran in and kicked the guy on the
ground
way to go yeah
it's just so
so we finished that conversation and
like that was the tightest squeeze i've
ever had from my father-in-law and he
like kissed me on the forehead and
they're all like thank you for talking
with us and bringing us together
and to be honest the relationship right
now is still a little awkward we're
trying to like rebuild and figure out
like
what that looks like now because it was
just
like it's just like it was just gone you
called them into a higher
a higher
way of being
yeah and now they got to learn how to
level up to you
they just got they got they got called
out they got held accountable to being
an adult good for you man yeah that's
going to be a stumbling season for a
while but good for you yeah and is your
husband walking around flexing now i can
just see him like wearing like a vest
with no sleeves being like yeah what's
up this is my house now you know what i
mean he kind of he kind of did to his
brothers he's like check out what you
know nessa did if they're like what what
happened what conversation happened
everybody's super shocked because they
just don't have conversations like that
yeah but you know
a certain point somebody's got to do it
you know and so i'm just like i need to
start taking care of myself and that's
when i switched jobs and i started
focusing on like my career and i was
really absorbing everything from my
school and like using like therapeutic
communication
okay but look at look at the progression
you had some childhood trauma
and you went to work
it was hard and then you began over time
to redeem that childhood trauma and most
of us just those we carry those bricks
in our backpack we listen to those
stories we were born into the stories we
were told and it becomes our destiny and
you said i'm not going to carry this
stuff forever so you worked on it as a
kid
probably just to breathe just to
function fair yeah
and as you became an adult you those
some of those bricks start showing back
up in your backpack because you we just
live how our parents lived and then you
got married to a
middle schooler i don't talk bad about
your husband but come on and so
uh he hadn't quite broken up with mommy
yet when y'all got married and then
y'all are together and together together
and then you came to a point said i'm
gonna process these feelings i'm gonna
look at these bricks i'm gonna demand
evidence from i'm gonna set this crap
down because i gotta be about living my
life and here's what you did you're so
brave and you had a hard conversation
face to face like an assassin
and then you know what you've done
you've changed the entire family
structure
now his brothers are going to live a bit
a little bit different they're going to
live differently
his parents are going to live
differently
he's going to you change the whole
family system
yeah yeah it felt really good
wow
it just really opened up like a lot of
communication between everybody and i
hear you know conversations between
because you know my husband was fighting
with his brother and fighting with his
parents and i hear the conversations of
like setting boundaries and you know
they're over the phone and they're like
actually you know we're not gonna do
this x y and z now and they're like okay
we'll see you when we see you or it
sounds good like let us know what the
plan is
nobody wants a piece of nessa anymore
like dude i'm gonna have nessa call you
dude
and then and then when you begin
redeeming these stories man you started
walking on these bricks and now you're
like and by the way i don't have to work
in this crappy job
i don't have to
i don't have to be a slave to my
feelings i don't have to i can go to i
can go to grad school dude everything is
changing
yeah
you're so freaking brave dude way to go
i really appreciate it well a lot of
that
you know when i called back in march
i was like in crisis mode i was trying
to get counseling through school and
they kept like not responding to
weightless eight years yeah
i need to talk to somebody
i'm losing my mind
and i think that you went so low as to
call a dude on a radio like on the pod
on a podcast that's how desperate you
were
it was pretty desperate
i appreciate it and you know i really a
lot of the way that
i navigate
through things
through learning like stuff through
wreck therapy
and then also just watching your show
like a lot of stuff really aligns with
this about how
important authenticity is and
communication and just
being vulnerable regardless of what
other people are going to think because
you need to be true to yourself and i i
for basically a year and a half almost
two years i lost myself i didn't know i
was i was just thick i wasn't in my
right mind so
i needed to get back to that place
man you
you're inspiring me
and i know you inspired that knuckle had
a husband of yours
and you inspired a whole family you're
inspired all people listening
dude
thank you for your bravery and for your
courage and dude i
these are the calls right they just go
into they go into the ether and i never
know what happens and so i'm so grateful
that you wrote back and you call back
and let's let's be super clear you could
have that conversation
and your parent your in-laws looked at
your husband
and they said
until she's gone we're out of here and
got up in life
that could have happened and i was i
went in with absolutely zero
expectations i'm like what's the worst
that could happen this could have cost
you already at rock bottom yes
and now what here we are and now what
and you went for it nessa
thanks for being awesome
an absolute dude
i'm not gonna fight you i don't know
we're ever gonna fight anyway but i'm
not messing with you that's incredible
absolutely you're a gift
you're a gift to your kids to your
family
to all our listeners thank you so much
for calling back thanks for being brave
man i could just
i could just sit here and talk to you
all day you're awesome wow
listen if you're listening you can
you can i don't even know what it is but
you can
and usually one
choice i'm going for a walk at 2am i'm
going for a walk i'm going to start
writing this stuff down i'm going to
write it down and i'm going to
plan it all out i'm going to vomit it up
like she said swear words anger
threats of arson whatever i'm going to
write it all down
i'm gonna sleep on it i'm gonna distill
what i wrote down when i vomited up into
some points and then i'm gonna look
somebody in the eye and say this is the
way this is gonna be from this point
forward because you're worth it
you only get one
tiny
precious little life
[Music]
you only get one
be like nessa that's the new t-shirt
everybody be like nessa we'll be right
back on the dr john de luna's show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndeloney.com and
get your copy of redefining anxiety
today
all right i'm still buzzing from that
last call huh but the nest is awesome
all right let's go to carmen in seattle
washington home of allison james what's
up carmen
hi how are you
i'm well how about yourself
well too well too hey
is the grunge sheen coming back are we
going to do this again or no
man yes my 14 year old
no joke was wearing a flannel
high-waisted like mom jeans they were
the pipe jeans do you remember those
yeah dude pearl jam jeans yes
yeah
it would ever go away i don't know not
the suicide part
the style part is fine
like a true seattle light you took this
thing real dark real fast so well done
okay so
hold on i'll never forget i think it was
i think it was like an interview with
vince neil or something the lead singer
of motley crue one of those and he said
something along the lines of
everybody's life is terrible that's why
we sing about like parties and craziness
like because all of our lives are awful
so he's thinking about this and he's
like i don't understand why
everyone in seattle just wants to sing
about how bad everything is and i
thought yeah
yeah
and then i talked to seattleite today
and i was like yeah things are great
but that could get worse there's no way
to go yeah dude oh that's so interesting
okay that's funny all right so what's up
how can i help
um
okay so
should we tell our teenage daughter that
her dad lost his faith and is now an
atheist oh okay tell me about it
what's the journey been like my
husband is a gift to me he's like every
answered prayer from my youth okay and i
had a hard childhood i'm a seven on the
asus scale or whatever
hold on hold on for a second
whoa
right
who's isn't i don't know
most seven is high
that's a hard hard childhood
not if you ask the parents
that's why
that's why in the aces scale or any sort
of trauma skill it's not
so what's your parents interpretation of
yeah that's not a question
um how did you meet this guy
stupid it's like i'm telling you it's
ridiculous
this guy was i was on the worship team
at church as a kid he's quite a bit
older than i am
and
he oh all like one day there was like
this new worship leader and i was like
okay that's weird
um well it turns out that this guy had
just come back from
a
training for
but it was like basically a two-year
mission where he went to get his
pastoral license
okay and
super devoted sort of an obnoxiously so
guy
but
then we
show him up oh gross all right i know
did he have did was he one of those
worship leaders that has like tight acid
wash sparkly jeans like with the
bejeweled jeans
please say yes that would never
ever
ever
you would never ever
hey that's all i needed to know good so
you married well all right good
cool so you you
are like
singing background vocals in like the
church
yeah and y'all are just like repeating
the same line over and over and over
again like worship music does and you
look over there and you're all alone
and you see this guy and you're like
he's not wearing bejeweled pants i think
i think i'm in okay so it was so funny
actually it's this is so funny so
and we've been married for almost
almost 16 years 16 or 17 years i'm not
sure a long time and we're best friends
we have very good open communication
with each other
we make fun of each other every day
um
and also support each other
anyway
so we have been married for like six
months
and
i was pregnant and it was really it was
kind of a
terminal truess
and crappy rocky
um yeah first start to the pregnancy
then our daughter was 11 months old and
we were driving to a birthday party on
like a saturday
and i said you know we were having some
sort of
i don't know
mundane conversation
and i and he said something that
triggered
me to ask him
well
like
jesus christ is lord and savior and
we're all sinners
and he was like i don't i actually don't
think that
and i
my
my response to him i'm an 8 on the
immunogram i don't know if you're into
that and uh you got lots of numbers
running your life good continue yeah
so he said i don't know oh my response
to him was
um
well that's that's a lie you've said
you've said differently for the last you
know i've known you for
five years like that's not
at that point right
that doesn't sound
accurate
and
that was kind of like the pandora's box
gotcha
um so has it taken 16 years for that to
slowly
or is he just no so he told me that
within the first year of marriage our
daughter was 11 months old at the time
now that 11 month old daughter
is you know 14 and three quarters
and she's wonderful
but he
he feels quite a bit of
cognitive dissonance about
his honesty level with the kids like
we're we've always kind of been big into
we've never been into santa like we
don't i just don't want to lie it's
great to you know have a santa on a
christmas bag or whatever but no
actually grandma and grandpa worked
really hard and that's where the gift
came from
okay all right
um very seattle of you
and why have joy in sparkles when we can
have gray sadness i know
uh no
hey man i wore shorts and tights with
doc martens back in the day too we've
all been there right i've had a flannel
shirt around my waist as well
okay so i actually thought that like
birkenstocks and wool socks together was
like
a like a universally accepted thing it's
it's it's not it's actually it's in the
dsm it's a it's a
psychological disorder but that's a
whole other thing
all right so
in your home
you've got a wonderful guy you'll love
him he's your best friend
oh my gosh and he
he has um
journeyed away from his his faith or
he's just on a different different path
for but she's going to say that and
does he still no he's an atheist like
he's an atheist
but yeah yeah but does he still saddle
up and go to church with you all every
week are you still in a part of your
faith community how are you raising your
kids how's that all working together
uh
well
i i deal in contracts for a living
holy smokes
no and he was super on board because he
actually when
when it all kind of came out to his
family who is i always say like they're
like the real quest christians like they
fight in a healthy way you know
and um try to live by
being kind to people when that all came
out to the family he
was very
i would say heartbroken
um because he was like honestly i never
wanted my parents to know they're in
their 80s
you know like i don't want to cause me
to stress his dad as a pastor was the
pastor of that church right so
let me get you made him tell his parents
no
okay
this or manipulated him into it
oh jeez
i know right so here this whole thing
like
so you may have heard me say this and i
got this from
dr bernie brown like
shame eats secrets for breakfast is the
way she says it
yeah
and the more secrets a family has the
more dysfunction there it is and the
more pathology is there is and then like
you literally live less long
like your body just reach itself right
and i've actually seen that
in real life like i saw this woman she
was a client i swear she died from
bitterness
45
yeah absolutely yes your body just says
i'm out they call it long tail suicide
like your body just begins to grind
itself to a halt it can't handle that
much stress those many stress hormones
but i'll also say this
we also
and
this is like towards answering your
question
we also when we have these epiphanies
these awakenings i do faith differently
than my parents did yeah i grew up with
parents who were very much
go find it on your own very much so and
we'll disagree and have conversations
but i i grew up with that kind of
support system so i get that but it
looks very different basically been what
we've done okay with our kids but listen
sometimes
when we have an epiphany about faith or
about covet or about relationships or
about whatever
we feel burdened by it and we feel like
we've got to announce it to everybody
you know the worst people are
crossfitters and diet people
oh i discovered this new gym it's and we
just proselytize everybody about your
dumb new gym or your weird diet
congratulations i'm glad this works for
you i i'm not in the tupperware or
essential oils or whatever the thing is
yeah and so we feel like we got to tell
everybody and it's not about them it's
about us
yes and we have to be okay in in when
somebody feels like i'm going to go tell
my 80 year old parents
yes i'm gonna break their hearts so i
can get this so i can live authentic
shut up
thank you
and this isn't even yours kristen like
i love you like getting after your
sister
so
you know what i mean it's it's both hand
yeah if my dad of 80 asked me hey how's
your faith be like hey man it's been 80
is very different than 14 you know what
your passion for his
yes like struggle with this because we i
you know i it's starting to feel like
we're being dishonest yeah technically
we never lied to you no no no yeah like
we're being dishonest yes so we're not
so does he like so just brass tacks does
he get up and
put on his non-sparkly jeans every
sunday and does he still lead worship at
a church does he
does he go with you all every week and
sing along and play along and does he do
that with y'all every week
so he has not led worship in
that actually so okay all this came out
on a saturday that next day sunday was
his last day of leaning worship so he
hasn't led worship in 14 and a half
years something like that so he's a man
he's a man of integrity
he's a man of integrity like we joined
trail life i don't know if you know what
that is but it's a no idea it's a
christ-centered scouting group for young
men and then there's a woman's one and
jesus in the woods baby yeah right
and he
did not
it wasn't even a question on whether or
not he was going to sign that statement
of faith gotcha you know so they
actually ended up writing they know us
because they know him he did a
background check on him all the things
they know us
but
you know he's not willing he's not going
to sign something that says
he's not gonna lie about his character
that's not true there you go yeah
cause signing that thing just to prove
he has character would mean he didn't
have character exactly exactly
no so so
so here's the thing with my daughter it
seems like if we told her and we've
gotten mixed counsel on this so it seems
to me that if we were to tell her and
then there's a 12 year old coming up
right behind her
that did all these things
then they're gonna it would be like us
putting like their our brick in their
backpack i don't feel that this is
something we're not even completely
so here's the brick that you're putting
in their backpack
the brick you're putting in their
backpack is they absorb the cognitive
dissonance
yeah they breathe
and they think at some level it's them
so
okay another little twist he actually my
husband
my husband knows biblical like he knows
the bible he has like a couple different
you know
like the latin yada yada
and so
you know we'll be having a discussion
and he's able to contribute
and
he's he's performing and he's but
and that's sort of how yeah and he's the
last right and so he that was how he got
attention whatever well
here's the deal
i think a
honest conversation with your 14 year
old is fair
in a
non-non-dumping his stuff onto her
because here's where it sounds like do
you tell me if i'm wrong
i'll go to task with anybody has a
church hurt a bajillion people yep oh
and yeah
do they continue to
take care of people all across the world
absolutely
yeah and so he sounds like a guy
who has lost the sensational parts of
the story the hard parts of the story
but has kept the practice
is still a person of character and
dignity does that make sense yes
yes train a child in the way they should
go and they will not depart from it when
they're older and i'm like it doesn't
say that they're gonna be saved well so
listen
i think it is he is gonna be able to
have this conversation without burning
the whole thing to the ground
for sure oh dang it dang it and he's on
the wrong side
oh are y'all competing
no i'm always competing everything is a
competition dude i'm just a dude on the
podcast yeah take my my this advice is
free right yes
yeah you're getting what you pay for
here but listen
okay here's where uh i'm and i'm gonna
i'm gonna
come after you in a second are you ready
yeah well let me do this so
i think it's worth a conversation of
truth
to say hey
i believe in these principles i believe
in
the
like here i'm not gonna put words in his
mouth here's what i did
and here's where the last
15 years
i've been been on a path and here's
where i am right now
yeah and i will tell you i had
long seasons of of being a full-blown
atheist i believe none of this nonsense
of my particular faith none of it i
thought it was insane
higher education's fault i'm just joking
it's super not um i know but
um then i had a set of experiences
being with people who'd lost people in
the middle like dealing with some dark
dark trauma
yeah and
it i got a different picture and a new
picture so what i would tell you is who
knows what two years from now looks like
in five years and ten years from now
looks like who knows what i would tell
you is i think being honest about
the path with his daughter is important
because then she goes oh and if he says
this is hard
and i loved the comfort of like being
honest about this path
hiding that journey from your daughter
is
she's just gonna internalize it
because she know she doesn't know that
dad's on contract with mom but she knows
you know what i
mean
dang it i never thought of it that way
she does
every morning from the way he
huffs the way he doesn't quite you know
he sits quietly in the back he doesn't
pick up the but he knows no
she knows
worship music and family gatherings when
we ask him to okay
when we ask him to and there will come a
moment when she's like man every time
you get in the car you put on motley
crue what you know i mean she'll ask
those questions
she'll know just like kelly's kids ask
those questions all right i'm just
kidding
do i force my husband to perform
yes and there's gonna that didn't that
that dissonance is all is is becoming
expressed in your kids dna
all right see how much he loves me he's
so great
okay and so here here's what's
here's what i don't think has happened
um i don't think you've made peace yet
no you no absolutely not carmen you're
hanging on to a fantasy you're hanging
on to a mix hanging on to a fantasy so
we agreed to before we got married
but you are trying to duct tape together
a picture of a family that all goes to
church together and all
does the little whatever i don't even
know it goes to
trailblazer jesus jesus in the woods
together we all do all these things
together and you you you trying so hard
to keep this picture together he's on
contract he's on contract
right you are so invested in this
picture and it's not real
and you've got to exhale
i am married to
and i love
an extraordinary man
who also
fill in the blame
and i don't think you've made peace with
that yet
that part
of him
right and that's a part of him
yeah
it's both in
and when you make peace with that
and you show your daughter
yeah as i this isn't the guy married but
he changed and yeah he's still
a guy who shows up and he's still a
person a character and i still love him
and he still loves you this is what
fidelity looks like this is what
marriage looks like you want to talk
about giving her gifts
you talk about her not picking up bricks
she's she knows what love looks like
you know what i mean
and right now by not having that
conversation you're you're
you're you're taking that opportunity
from her so it's an incredible i think
it's by poe bronson um it's been a
couple years since i read it's called
nurture shock one of the things i
remember from that book uh that is years
ago and we'll link to it in the show
notes it's uh what i remember was it was
a phenomenal book i remember closing it
going whoa but he says that
a lot of parents our generation of
parents were told don't fight in front
of the kids
if you have disagreements in front of
the kids you're going to freak them out
you're going to scare them and you're
going to think their world's coming
apart yeah and so what parents did was
they went in the back bedroom and fought
and then they came out a united front or
whatever somebody won somebody lost
whatever or a very united front that was
a silent front how about that
and what bronson points out is we stole
from our children
a picture of how two people love each
other and disagree and then still make
dinner together
right and now we have a world where if
we have a disagreement we think oh
that's it we're out of love and then we
break up and move on or we go post crap
about each other oh we can't get it i
mean i think this has rippled through
our culture politically
dietary through everything
and so by saying yeah me and your dad
man it made me sad because i still
believe in my faith with all of my heart
and
but we do have we do believe in
principles and she'll ask natural
questions like
was what if dad decides he doesn't love
me and those are hard i know but those
are hard things that a 14 year old asks
what is that because yeah yeah what if
he decides he doesn't love you
then your daughter gets a ringside seat
to love is a risk
and then he gets to look at her i'd say
i will never leave you
yeah you know what i mean and so these
are hard
these are real and they are gritty
but i i will always go to a foundation
financial intent of my life is
never lie to your kids and right now
y'all are lying to your kids
um
lying just not telling the whole truth
yes that's true right and i i say that
i'm being direct with you but we're
you're my friend
um time
exactly
um
show her that you and your husband are
still connected and married yeah and in
love and you have different faiths
one faith no faith
let her
know that cognitive dissonance is y'alls
not hers
right
and she may ask questions and say yeah
this is where i land
and not hers so instead of okay so the
way i've been thinking about it is like
we're putting our brick in her backpack
but really it's it's you know taking
that brick out of her backpack and
saying identifying it and saying this is
what it is
you know you probably have felt things
yeah
do you have any questions yep or she
might say how could dad have played the
charade for so long she feels betrayed
absolutely she should feel betrayed heck
yeah you know what i mean and not in a
no no no no seriously she should feel
betrayed and that's okay because you're
saying like you can't fix the last 14
years you can just go forward now
right yeah yeah
and i still think it's good for
um
i think the data plays out go to church
they even have atheist church popping up
people get to get there and sing
together and they show up once a week
and they it's almost like uh how to do
community the the practice is important
it's been going on for thousands of
years so i still think he goes to church
with you
if he was on the phone i was talking to
him i'd say dude i think you still go i
think you still there's
high high value i think you still give i
think you still serve i think you still
participate
i really really do
i feel strongly about that what kept me
alive as a person was in my seasons of
doubt i kept going i kept going
and some of it was just to keep the
peace in my home some of it was i had a
job where at like a faith-based
organization i had to you know i mean
but you just keep going and you keep
going just like there's seasons when i
don't want to work out and you just get
up and do it anyway and there's seasons
when man one more drink would be awesome
and you don't or a donut would be
awesome and you don't you don't
i mean sometimes donuts are so cute fine
but but listen listen now you got me
thinking about donuts and
that happens to talk
but i think you keep going with the
practice because the practice is right
practice is good
and i would
really encourage you to sit down because
you you haven't come to terms with this
yet for four years
i was a child i was 18 years old yeah
yeah yeah you know how much frontal lobe
development have you had at 21. it's
like you know what i mean
yeah yeah but here we are so we can't go
backwards we can only go forwards
and i was well and i don't think it's
going to be appropriate for her to tell
to tell her brothers this is not a
stance you know
absolutely you know this is and we
actually have a phrase in our families
it's like this is family business that
means you don't talk about it with
anybody but us
well right yes but you got to be careful
about that because i know it turns into
a
yeah that gets gnarly right right it's
like keeping a secret
that's true that's right and so i i
don't want yeah just be careful with
that type of language but you can't let
them know this is dad talking privately
and i'm going to ask you to not um not
tell people oh that's a good phrase but
this is my story and i want to share my
story with you
and my story is not your story
and your mommy you though do i share my
story with her absolutely yes
absolutely yes now the details of all
seven aces probably not right but
she's gonna feel it
because there's gonna be moments when
she's 14 15 and 16 that your body
remembers what you went through
yeah oh my gosh yeah it remembers and so
yeah that gap you feel that uh uh you're
that no or that guy's gonna show up to
the house and you're gonna be like you
get that guy at it you know what i mean
those kind of things will happen and
she's gonna think it's already happened
i know and she's gonna think it's her
and i want her to know she actually says
why don't you trust me like what have i
done
to show you that you can't trust me and
i'm like
it's not about you it's about other
people
no it's only about me and he's my
husband says that i think it's time i
think it's time i mean you're all going
to blow up your 14 year old girl's
little little precious world
oh my goodness she has a therapy she
goes she has a therapist she goes well
yeah here we go right but i think i
think a season of honesty and truth
telling and storytelling is is important
and letting her know she's got her story
and i'll i'll end this call with this um
i i think i may have talked about this
on the show
um i was at an event and doing a q a
there's a thousand people out there
somebody came up and said i realize i've
put a lot of bricks in my kids backpack
how do i help them get it out
and
i told him you can't
when a brickpick brick goes into
somebody's backpack whether it's trauma
whether it's a story they were told
whether it was a story they were born
into about faith or religion or
exercise or how we eat whatever the
story is
about what you're worth what men and
women do all this
stuff
once a brick goes in their backpack
that's their journey that's their
adventure once it's in it doesn't it
doesn't come in i mean you're not
getting it out that's their job that's
their adventure so the goal for a parent
is to put as few bricks in a kid's
backpack because the world's gonna dump
a bunch of them in there a bunch and
kids are gonna do stupid stuff all
adults we're gonna do dumb things we're
gonna not tell our kids a story for 14
years and now we've got to do it that's
her adventure now
that's her adventure
she will come to see both of you as man
i was hard i was honest and you all were
two kids figuring out life and i'm great
fill in the blank and there will be some
pain there that's part of being a parent
part of kids
but once the brick goes in that's theirs
and so how few bricks can we put in our
kids backpack that ends up being the
journey but carmen i'm grateful for the
call
man it's awesome to talk to a woman
who's married to a great guy loves her
husband he's got great kids and is
working hard to do right by your kids
and by the way
you're redeeming your childhood
you went through
hell and you are doing the redemptive
work and you've got the scars to prove
it and your daughter's gonna have a
different life because of the work you
and your husband put in and i'm grateful
for you that's awesome
it's awesome
all right as we wrap up today's show
what do you think james do we want to do
uh
a classic
or a guy letting his feelings be known
with an acoustic guitar
let's go classic
i don't even know what record this is on
this is uh so classic
but it's by the one and only annie linux
walking on broken glass
it goes like this that's not what wasn't
the melody at all really
kind of whiffed it
any linux songs walking on broken glass
this is a call back to the other day
when
kelly smashed my picture of my childhood
friends
in rage and anger
and maybe a little bit of alcoholism it
goes like this
walking on broken glass you were the
sweetest thing that i ever knew but i
don't care for sugary honey if i can't
have you since you abandoned me my whole
life has crashed once you pick up the
pieces once you pick the pieces up
because it feels just like i'm walking
on broken glass kelly
walking on broken glass the sun's still
shining in the big blue sky but it don't
mean nothing to me let the rain come
down let the wind blow through me i'm
living in an empty room dude this song
got dark
kelly with all the windows smashed and
i've got so little left to lose it feels
like
i'm walking on broken glass
just like working on the dr john
deloney's show we'll see you all soon
take care